foreign
[Music]
Chuck yes I have a like an urgent
explainer uh oh
urgent
urgent what did you do now
no there's a green comet in the sky and
people have been asking questions about
it yes I thought let's pop this
explainer out there just so we can
settle some green Comet issues issues
that's correct you have to be confused
with the Green Hornet no not to be
confused at all with the Green Hornet
who by the way was not cool at all Cato
was really the cool one of course I only
watched it for Cato yeah
Green Hornet was just a white guy with a
Lincoln
that's all it was like it was a white
dude with a nice Lincoln whip right and
and but the Asian guy that could kick
your ass that was the Radio Action was
Bruce Lee was really where all the
action was man I don't care about your
green ring let me let me let me
roundhouse you in the face exactly
all right so uh this comment was
discovered last year okay and by the way
for what it's worth in case you didn't
know we discover hundreds of comets a
year all right and and in some cases
depending on which telescopes are tasks
to it in some cases it could even be
thousands
so the act of discovering a comet is not
itself extraordinary okay make that
clear right most of those comments never
get bright enough to be visible to the
unaided eye you do telescopes and you
have to know where to look and since
they're moving you have to know where to
look today versus yesterday which is
going to be different from where you
have to look tomorrow right so this one
in particular
based on its trajectory based on how
bright it has been for the past few
months because it's headed doing this
deep Loop orbit around the sun Crossing
Earth's orbit to do that okay so this
Comet as it descends towards the Sun as
you know as you may know the heat from
the Sun uh it will will evaporate the
ice right right the technical word there
is some it subliminates the ice because
evaporate is what we would say if liquid
turns to gas but if you go from solid to
gas it's called sublimation that's
what's happening with the comet we all
know sublimation that's what dry ice
does right so
you have a comet that's coming in it was
unknown before so last year was it was
discovered
so there's no record of it ever having
come before when you look at its orbit
we find out that its orbit is
50 000 Years Around the Sun so
50. nope the caveman was not checking
this out wow
all right now with so the Sun's gravity
is that
uh heavy that it's it's badass no son's
gravity goes well beyond damn tune the
last planet from the sun right get over
it yeah I was about to say when you said
the last play I was like damn he did it
again
so it goes well beyond Neptune it goes
into the Kuiper belt right of comets
right all right and where Pluto is a
member one of the prominent members of
the Kuiper belt of comets and and then
beyond that there's a repo a spherical
repository of Frozen objects comets that
goes practically halfway out to the
nearest star wow this was predicted to
be there by a Dutch astronomer named Jan
ort and it's called the orc liquor Cloud
oh the ort Cloud cool so this Comet
comes to us from the Oort clown
wow and any comment that comes to us
from the work cloud has never been seen
in the in Civilization all right because
that's how that's how long those
trajectories take okay so here's what I
gotta ask because you said that it was
bright
no I didn't say it was bright I said it
was it was bright enough so that it
might be visible to the unaided eye
that's why it's making the news oh okay
okay so I saw a headline just to show
you how how Wishful we are the headline
in a major news Outlet said a new bright
comet is discovered it may be visible to
the unaided eye that's right
no
can we have truth in advertising here
please that's right yeah all right it's
definitely visible in telescopes right
now and it has already come past the Sun
so it's already at its own intrinsic
brightest but now it's going to work its
way back out
of the solar system and it'll come
closer towards Earth so after it dips
around the Sun it'll be best viewed in
our Northern skies in the last week of
January as it passes by the North Star
all right just coincidentally and North
North Star which itself is not
particularly bright but you can always
find it by looking at the much brighter
stars that comprise the Big Dipper and
the lip of the Big Dipper points points
approximately to the North Star so
that's how you find it so so if you look
up with your eyes and you don't see it
it's because the comet is not as bright
as the headlines are telling you and
binoculars are good you can sort of scan
the sky with binoculars but what's good
about that last week of of January is
that the moon will not be competing in
brightness with that comet in the sky
and because the moon could just blow it
out but totally blows it out totally
blows it out I like it so the Moon is
not the stargazer's friend at all unless
you're looking at the moon itself yeah
all right and then that's all you're
going to be looking at because nothing
else is good the Moon is jealous yeah so
why so why is it green well we can
spectroscopically analyze the comet put
the light through them through through a
prism through a version of a prism and
you see all the chemistry that's going
on and we know that there are a couple
of ways you can get green one of them is
from the molecule cyanogen
all right science CN basically Cyanogen
and did you know that Cyanogen is
poisonous I you know I was about to say
I heard I hear Cyanide and Cyanogen no
yeah it's related they're related
there's like Sienna is an active uh part
of the larger molecule that's cyanide
right it's hydrogen cyanide is the is
the full molecule there but CN is
poisonous okay okay do you know that the
first time we detected Cyanogen in a
comet was for Halley's Comet in 1910.
and let me guess the person who looked
up at it through the telescope dropped
dead and we were like oh that is a
poisonous comment here it is we got the
Spectra of it this got announced
people lost their [ __ ] okay people
people because we we were also projected
to pass through the tail okay
1910 and there were headlines God just
poisoned the world headline thing end of
the world is coming and so people
started selling anti-comet pills oh
that's amazing these little vowels take
this to protect you from the poisonous
gases of the Comet others had
um uh umbrella protection they'd sell
you anti-comet umbrellas wow it was it
was like oh my gosh you you think the
movie don't look up had crazy social
public phenomena going on in it you go
back to 1910. because everyone was
anticipating Haley's Comet because it
was the most famous of all comets and it
just takes a 76-year path hardly anyone
alive then saw it in its previous voyage
and nobody lived very long yeah that
thing yeah back then not many yeah 36
was like ancient no
you're a 55 year old man would get in
the wheelchair for you exactly so the
point is Cyanogen has this fascinating
history with Haley's Comet from 1910.
nice and here's another weird thing
about comets in 1910 there was another
Comet that came out in January that was
brighter than Haley's Comet
okay another one of these sort of once
in a in a uh it was probably also from
the Oort cloud Haley's Comet is not from
the earth Cloud it comes around like I
said every seven six years or so years
are you coming from the work Cloud
nobody saw you before you just show up
and it was really bright many people
who believed they were remembering
Haley's Comet telling stories about 1910
we're giving accounts of that other
Comet based on how they described it
right so that other Comet supplanted
many people's memories for what they uh
think they were seeing back in 1910. I
got you kind of kind of like
um you know
um every eyewitness to a black man
committing a crime
it's got to be about police
now please back to the comments All
right so since comets are just these
these these aggregations of ice of very
of many different kinds just water ice
ammonia ice CO2 ice which is dry ice
more commonly called so as it nears the
sun it's tumbling and it's heated and
it's very hard to predict how visible it
will get because the visibility relates
to how much gas sublimates off the comet
oh because then the guests will do two
things it can fluoresce in the high
energy light of the Sun but it can also
reflect light and most of the tail that
you see of a comet is reflected light
right and so the more gas evaporates
the more it can reflect light and the
more visible it becomes so the more
flatulent the comment is did I use that
did I did
no I'm just saying it just sounds like
you know you got a comment and had a
very aggressive lunch
now another another fact okay is the
gases that evaporate and form what we
call the tail the pressure from sunlight
pushes the tail in the opposite
direction of wherever the sun is at all
times
okay okay so when a comet comes in
towards the Sun
we can think of that as an authentic
tale because it's trailing the comet
right but on its way out from the Sun
it exits tail first
wow okay so tail is a little bit of a
misnomer gotcha
okay gotcha right oh oh my God yes
because when we think of a tale here we
think of it because there's an air
current that creates a tail but because
you're moving because you're moving
through the air but there is no errands
no yes nowhere so it's so the if the
sun's radiation is pressure pushing the
tail then it will actually precede the
comment when it's on its way out correct
so comets go in head first and go out
tail first wow kind of like me having an
argument with my wife noise
so if you want to get a sense of which
way the tail would point when you're
looking for it this last week of January
near the in and around and near the
North Star remind yourself where the sun
is uh okay or a headset and then the
tail would be pointing in the opposite
direction of that if you want to see
what that's oh that's so cool what that
does so so that's just the highlights of
it so it may be visible to the unaided
eye if you have good binoculars
um and by the way if you there's there
are websites that you can go to that
show you exactly we can't do this in an
explainer but show you exactly where it
is relative to the Big Dipper and the
North Star each day okay because it's
moving fast but it's not moving so fast
that oh I just missed it oh my gosh it
whisper right exactly people think a
comet is oh I missed it this last minute
no it's there for the meteor
that would be immediate inching its way
across the sky against the rest of it so
basically this is not as big a story as
these people are making it out to be
it'll even be visible to the unaided eye
and what the I might be delighted if it
were her but I would I just want to
temper your expectations so what the
headline should say is newly discovered
comet much like a Lauren Hill or Guns
and Roses concert
you might see it you might not
they're too too musical acts that were
notorious for selling tickets and then
just not going on this is guns and Rose
from the 1980s was it the 80s no no no
no no no they were the 90s but when was
their last album I don't know the
century I don't think no it wasn't this
Century yeah yeah okay yeah okay okay so
audience that joke from Chuck was for a
particular age demographic come on now
you got out of No Guns and Roses oh how
did you not
Association I just saw a slash in the
commercial yesterday yes you did okay
okay a little patience yes Welcome to
the Jungle people yeah all right we're
we're comets may or may not show up
I can guarantee the comment's not going
to be like oh my gosh let me put on my
shades that is not gonna happen all
right but if you heard about it now you
know where the green comes from and
there are a couple of other sources of
green but Cyanogen is a good one and
Cyanogen is a c and an N carbon and
nitrogen two very common ingredients
Across the Universe wow and the good
thing the interesting thing about comets
is that the nobody's been messing with
the comment it spends most of his life
halfway across to the nearest stars and
so
if you if you retrieve a sample of comet
you will see the the birth ingredients
of the solar system itself wow that's
why the study of comets is so important
among those who studies oh my God
they're they're like space fossils yes
yes
so cool that is so cool so we got to
wrap it there chuck all right damn it
this was good yeah yeah the green Comet
the green Comet and if someone's selling
you comic pills no no and better yet if
somebody has a common umbrella they're
calling you an idiot
now if they're trying to sell you the
umbrella they think you're an idiot
right exactly you got it all right there
it is comet in the skies the Neil
deGrasse Tyson here thanks Chuck for
being there always a pleasure all right
uh as always keep looking up
there might be a comic band
[Music]